[Musik]
dosen croissants versprechen
kinderleichten genuss zum frühstück
sebastian zeigt was in fertig
blätterteig steckt bei den kollegen ist
alles andere außer butter drin und
nelson macht den geschmackstest muss es
wirklich die marke sein
was sagt ihr zu diesem großen croissants
habt ihr da eine verbindung oder der
inneren knacken back klar ganz
bestimmten geruch auf gebacken wird man
schmeckt richtig bei uns verlassen
sonntags dinge das gab es also relativ
regelmäßig das wohl sein vorher noch mit
mit eigelb bepinseln
mama hat alles gegeben und sohn war
begeistert rosenkranz versprechen vor
allem eine einfache handhabung nelsons
dessen rollen erst einmal die marken
croissants aus
[Musik]
nach was riecht das denn für euch sorry
ich mutter bin ich schon noch bäckerei
finde ich ja kommen wir machen noch mal
ein nebenprodukt aufnehmen ihr dürft
euch eins aussuchen
aber es gibt so klar jetzt schon so
aussahen wie das schon raus
[Musik]
und auch wenn es in der hand hast dann
bricht das auch sofort aus
das markenprodukt kostet mehr als das
doppelte
in sachen handhabung überzeugt die
künftige discounter variante von lidl
doch was essen wir da eigentlich welche
zutaten braucht es für ein croissant auf
der dose
das schaut ja ich heute etwas drin und
schockiert natrium hydrogencarbonat
alkohol speisesalz mono und diese zur
rede von speise fettsäuren politikerin
esther er gar nicht das drin was mich
erwartet was da drin ist
ich würde denken da drin ein bisschen
oder irgendwie sowas ob marke oder
nonnen beide zutatenlisten erinnern eher
an ein chemielabor
dabei suggerieren die verpackungen
blätterteig mit ordentlich butter
[Musik]
produktentwickler sebastian lege weiß
was wirklich drin steckt er zeigt uns
die geheimnisse des frühstücks klassiker
zum frisches croissant mit seiner
morgendlichen butter wolke ist schon was
schönes
bei den kollegen ist alles andere außer
butter drin keine butter inkubation
sebastian nutzt bei seiner kreation den
gleichen krieg wie die industrie ganz
wichtig günstiges pflanzenfett schmeckt
nach nichts sieht nach nichts aus kann
man ganz leicht verändern
echte butter wäre viel zu teuer
deshalb soll aus pflanzenfett eine
möchtegern butter werden als erstes der
geschmack butter aroma kostengünstig
paar tropfen auf billiges pflanzenfett
doch das hart dass er so hoch
konzentriert deshalb nur wenige tropfen
fehlt noch der richtige anstrich
farbstoff aus karotten beta carotin
heißt das zauberwort
ein paar tropfen und unser pflanzenfett
sieht aus wie butter
trotz aroma und farbstoffe dieses
pflanzenwelt ist immer noch günstiger
als echte butter und laut
lebensmittelgesetz ganz legal
[Musik]
es riecht nach butter es ist genauso
schön gelb wie butter es ist gar keine
butter jetzt kommt der teig klassischer
blätterteig besteht neben mutter nur aus
mehl salz hefe und wasser aber auch hier
weiß der produktentwickler wie getrickst
wird er ersetzt die hefe durch chemische
back tribute die wahl hätte würde viel
zu lange dauern
batterie mittels akdag muss der teig
nicht lange ruhen und geht regelmäßig
gleich in die dose das spart zeit und
geld
eine letzte geheim zu tat gemacht ja
noch das ist wirklich echte alkohol
ob marke oder ein produkt die dosen
croissants enthalten etwa ein prozent
ethylalkohol der stopp den rang beim
gehen
[Musik]
ohne alkohol würden die dosen im laden
aufplatzen
nachdem aufbacken verfliegt der alkohol
jedoch restlos einmal durchkneten und
schon kann der produktentwickler den
teig ausrollen jetzt kommt das billige
fett zum einsatz
[Musik]
echte mächtigen butter her
die trägt sebastian jetzt ganz dünn auf
der trick beim blätterteig das feld muss
schichtweise zwischen dem teig nur so
wird das croissant am ende schön fluffig
[Musik]
vier mal rollt sebastian aus trägt fällt
auf und faltet den teig am ende formt er
die dreiecke die wir aus den dosen
können und die nur noch in den ofen
müssen
[Musik]
und wie gut ist sein industrie croissant
ohne echte butter
[Musik]
na ja gar nicht so schlecht oder
also dieses blättrigen fluffige mutige
erlebnis von meinem lieblings bäcker um
die ecke ist das ziemlich beim bäcker
kostet ein butter kreuzung aber auch im
schnitt etwa einen euro 20 für einen
losen großen vom marktführer zahlen wir
dagegen weniger als 30 cent
und nun ist mit 17 sind sogar noch
günstiger
billig oder teuer gibt es mehr
unterschiede als nur den preis
sternekoch nelson müller hat aufgebacken
knack und back gegen das discounter
produkt von lidl
beide sind gleich schnell fertig wenn
jetzt so beide vergleicht für welches
produkt würdet ihr euch entscheiden auch
vielleicht den preis im kopf haben
gerade im hinblick auf den preis will
ich auf jeden fall das konzert das ist
ein bisschen fester ist auch eine
schönere farbe
das kann ich besser schneiden ich kann
mir sachen drauf legen dass es erstens
gäste sind sich einig in sachen geruch
konsistenz und beim preis liegen die
domains vorn aber was schmeckt besser
100 tester können nicht irren
in der xxl blindverkostung haus aus der
dose
marke und nun eben in geschmacks du in
[Musik]
der marktführer knapp und back tritt an
gegen lidl chef select unternehmens
testpersonen finden wir auch echte knack
und back liebhaber wie helene aus berlin
kleine tendenz ist ja eher so ein
bisschen das duo ihre marken produkte
einkaufen meine mutter hat das schaffst
du auch mal gekauft für mich um meine
schwester und wenn man es immer mal ganz
gerne gegessen weil sie einfach eben und
so luftig locker gebacken sind geben und
die handhabung ist ganz einfach ja und
der geschmack ist eben auch ganz lecker
muss ich sagen ich hatte auch mal die
vom lidl gekauft im discounter und ich
finde dass die süßer sind als die von
merkel oder noch nie wer macht das
rennen
wir backen die croissants genauso wie es
auf der verpackung steht und
portionieren immer gleich
es kommt allein auf den geschmack an
marken liebe und vertrauen spielen im
blind ist keine rolle
die tester wissen nicht welches produkt
sich auf welchem level befindet knack
und back gegen die dosen kreishaus von
lidl probe 1 oder 2 was schmeckt besser
nelson müller kind das ergebnis der
teilnehmer hast du deine marke erkannt
oder was ist passiert
ich habe also ich meine schon dass ich
es erkannt habe und das zweite ist dass
christoph von knapp und buck das meinst
du das mal nicht so süß wie das erste
helene ist knacken wachsen
ja du hast du eine marke leider nicht
erkennt nein aber wenn ich das gibt's ja
nicht nur geärgert was er kann und wir
haben die 100 probanden insgesamt
abgestimmt das ergebnis ist deutlich
drei viertel aller tester haben sich für
knapp und back entschieden
der sieger in unserem geschmackstest das
markenprodukt es schon sehr erstaunlich
dass knack und back geschmacklich so
deutlich besser abschneidet als synonym
varianten aber immerhin kostet die marke
natürlich auch mehr als das doppelte
darf ein großer auch mal aus der dose
sein sagt es uns in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer essen
wissen wollt dann abonniert die zdf
besser esser und schaut in die nächsten
zwei clips
[Musik]